herr was ist nur in europa los dass
analysiere ich jetzt mit peter tiede
chefreporter ist unsere politik ressort
du hast auch noch mal die karte vor der
die wir vorhin eingeblendet haben diese
dramatische zeit um uns herum ist alles
rot muss uns angst machen also respekt
muss es uns auf jeden fall einflüssen ob
angst da der richtige ratgeber es war
nicht mal zu bezweifeln aber respekt
sollten wir haben und nicht ganz so
sorglos sein ob man jetzt die
stimmungslage und unserer
bundeskanzlerin die sich am samstag noch
mal an die nation gewandt hat per
videobotschaft ob man direkt zu
übernehmen muss sei mal dahingestellt
aber wir sollten respekt haben und wir
sollten vorsichtig sein weil das was um
uns herum passiert ist symptomatisch
zögern jetzt haben wir einige beispiele
von unseren nachbarländern gesehen immer
wieder schweden als vorzeigeland wie
toll ist die krise meistert ist das denn
übertragbar was macht schweden so
besonders
geben sie uns vielleicht lösungen vor an
denen man sich orientieren könnte man
kann sich an gewissen schritten die
schweden gegangen ist sicherlich
orientieren zur wahrheit gehört auch
schweden ist sondern
bevölkerungsstruktur her und von der
bevölkerung nicht daher überhaupt nicht
vergleichbar mit deutschland maximal
vergleichbar mit mecklenburg vorpommern
und teilen brandenburgs und dort haben
wir ähnlich niedrige werte wie wir sie
in schweden haben momentan noch unser
wahrheit gehört auch deutschland ist
dichter am schwedischen weg dran gewesen
als zum beispiel an dem weg den spanien
gegangen ist also wir durften raus unser
lockdown war ein relativ sanfter
lockdown wir durften raus die kinder
durften spielen gehen das war in anderen
staaten europas nicht der fall was uns
jetzt sorgen machen muss es das ist
wirklich direkt in grenzen hier bei uns
hoch schlägt und da wirklich dramatische
ausmaß annimmt
peter was bedeutet das konkret müssen
die grenzen wieder dicht machen also die
überlegung gibt es ja schon da wird seit
dem wochenende auch tatsächlich darüber
diskutiert und wir haben auch diverse
stimmen in einem beitrag online wo
darüber diskutiert wird ob wir
tatsächlich jetzt die grenze schließen
müssen was wir nicht mehr erleben werden
glaube ich sind landesweite harte
maßnahmen wenn die grenzen zugemacht
werden dann werden an den grenzen
kontrolliert werden also es keine ist da
geht nicht dass pfeil runter oder die
oder die burg treppe wird hochgezogen
sondern dann können die pendler
weiterreisen gibt wird dann was wir
schon erlebt haben auch aus dem
grenzraum frankreich dann werden die
pendler extra bescheinigungen haben dass
sie zur arbeit fahren dürfen und der
güterverkehr und der warenverkehr
wird weiter gegeben seien ansonsten
würden wir uns selber töten dann würden
wir die wirtschaft runterfahren und das
wäre nicht zu vereinbaren also wir
werden zu bestimmten gebieten sicherlich
wenn sich die lage nicht entspannt
grenzkontrollen bekommen wieder das muss
der bundesinnenminister ist durchs
kabinett bringen und dann muss das
deutschland erstmal bei der eu
beantragen oder zumindest anmelden das
ist anders als in österreich da haben
wir die genehmigung deswegen wird er
kontrolliert aber mittelfristig ist die
antwort ja eine sache muss man jedoch
positiv sehen wir sind im europäischen
vergleich eigentlich geld bisher ganz
gut durch die krise gekommen ist scheint
aber so als würden die deutschen das
derzeit gar nicht so wahrnehmen woran
liegt es ist es gibt in der physik gibt
es ein modell das ist die population
also wenn ein kaffeefilter nimmst und du
sitzt und ein kaffeefilter und obendrauf
das immer in den kaffeefilter rein und
das um das kaffeepulver dann sitzt du da
unten und sagte da passiert gar nichts
das ist ja gar nicht schlimm und alle
waren gleich gleichkommt du sitzt unten
drunter erst führt das wasser die den
gesamten zwischenraum zwischen dem
kaffeepulver dann ist das kaffeepulver
irgendwann mal durchnässt und dann
irgendwann ist das papier durchnässt und
dann läuft der kaffee durch und es
tropft und in der phase scheinen wir
momentan zu sein das sagen zumindest die
virologen das glaubt auch frau merkel
das ist jetzt angefangen hat zu tropfen
und wenn es jetzt weiter tropft dann ist
das erst mal nicht zu stoppen für die
nächsten wochen bis oben dicht ist und
dann läuft es nach dessen sogenannte
nachlaufeffekt von dem auch immer frau
merkel spricht und das ist die gefahr
die wir im moment haben dass wir das
unterschätzen weil erst mal nichts
passiert ist man darf es auch nicht
überschätzen weil 1 haben wir wir haben
ein anderes gesundheitssystem als die
meisten länder um uns herum wir haben
mehr intensivbetten wir haben eine
höhere krankenhaus dichte das ist auch
eine folge des föderalismus wir sind
anders aufgestellt und wir haben
tatsächlich dann in deutschland seit dem
frühjahr wirklich krankenhausbetten
intensivbetten aufgebaut wir haben also
mehr
deswegen können wir momentan auch
nachbarstaaten anbieten ihr könnt euren
erkranken auch zu uns bringen eben
welche auf noch haben wir die
möglichkeiten und der große wert um den
es immer ging war das gesundheitssystem
und darf nicht überlastet werden jetzt
noch zwei sachen hinzugekommen das hat
die bundesregierung auch ganz klar
gesagt es geht um die wirtschaft die
wirtschaft darf nicht runter gefahren
wird und die kinder müssen weiter zur
schule können
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergibt
nicht zu abonnieren